[Music]
you're watching day 1 of game sports
play for all event and it is my great
pleasure to be joined by Tim Sweeney and
Kim library of epic games how's it going
guys good fantastic
obviously you guys have had quite a few
weeks you unveiled Unreal Engine 5 and
talked about the future of you know the
the engine that kind of powers as much
of the video game industry so I think we
want to dive in quickly into the really
important stuff and obviously the most
important thing from your recent
revelation where Tim Sweeney had for
some reason a plasma ball in the
background of his interview Tim can you
tell us about the story behind the
plasma ball please
sure well this is your world excuse of
the day so we're preparing for a Geoff
Keeley show and realized it was going to
be filmed and so the the mess that was
behind me in my office need to be
cleaned up so I was running around
hitting up the office I knocked over my
diet coat which I always have with me
and so I in this giant spill of Diet
Coke there and we were about to begin
filming in like 30 seconds so I grabbed
the nearest object which was this ball I
think from Spencer's at the mall and it
was covering up the diet cokes belt and
nobody nobody was the wiser
this wild conspiracy theory about what
it was meant to symbolize for the record
does it symbolize anything about the
future or fortnight or Unreal Engine 5
no no I mean you would say that wouldn't
you but so the way the way we approach
for tonight it's the work of an awesome
creative team I last designed to be in
myself and in 1992 the other thing that
people want to know is are you a a a
Popeye's or a Wendy's person sometimes
Bojangles goes it is very good to Kim
Kim what's your what's your a restaurant
of choice oh my goodness my rest no
choice but in terms of fast food
restaurants unfortunate come get it here
but it's it will be a little cheeky
nandos every so often Nando's yes
you can't Kagura the Britain you cheeky
Nando's why my accent may have mutated
over the last 20 years but I still like
a bit of Nando's when I go fantastic
we're on the
cusp of a generational transition you've
unveiled new technology that will push
gaming forward and various other mediums
taking a slightly retrospective look
what has been your key takeaways from
the generation that was what do you
think that we as an industry as develop
as yourself and people who are behind
you know engines and various other
things to do in gaming what do we do
good and what do you think we could do
better yeah with this generation we
pushed a lot of things to the limit I
love amazing lighting and rendering
technology is the marched here we've
been able to do some pretty impressive
open-world games with big scenes you
know fortnight with a hundred players in
a massive multiplayer game and so amount
of dynamic lighting but we've we've
really run up against a brick wall in
terms of achieving absolute photo
realism and so it's been a it's been an
interesting learning process we just
kind of got to the door of photorealism
but couldn't quite get in at the same
time this is the console generation when
Microsoft and Sony and Nintendo finally
came together and opened up
cross-platform play and we saw gaming
emerged as a social phenomena in this
generation you know we're a fortnight
and rocket League now call of duty and
lots of other games are connecting all
the different players across all the
platforms and the single live game
environment with all their friends and
that's been a really great boon for the
industry I think this generation has
some really great storytelling in
videogames I think that the the you know
division between films and games as
being good storytelling mediums is sort
of it's been whittled away a lot in this
generation and I think this this
phenomena that you can go to a virtual
world and hang out with your friends and
do cool things that are different every
night is something that I think that the
games industry can be really really
proud of that we you know we've made a
destination for people to have
entertainment that isn't you know in in
normal physical spaces and obviously you
know during the situation where and
we're not right now with Corbett 19
games have brought people together
people across the whole planet can
interact in ways they would do if they
were in the same space but within a
virtual world so I think that the big
multiplayer social experiences a bit is
probably one of the most exciting parts
of the last generation for sure I think
one of the interesting things or perhaps
something that's being lost in
translation or it perhaps isn't clear to
when you reveal the engine a lot of it
was about triangles for example and
photorealism but I think what people
might not have as good a grasp on is
like the applicability of Unreal Engine
beyond photo realism obviously you can
take that engine and create all kinds of
various styles but can you talk a bit
about how it can be used within gaming
not just for photo realism but how it
empowers a variety of our art styles and
a variety of experiences making a great
world environment characters is not you
know for realism isn't doesn't have to
be part of that
what matters is detail and richness and
believable about the implausibility of
the environment you're in so you know
the techniques that we use for photo
realism also apply you know very very
well to completely stylized in
prominence in fact now when I used to
work in the movie business type you know
things did a lot of movies with the
Wachowskis and we did one movie called
speed racer and speed ratio is found it
completely on the principles of
photorealistic rendering but is made to
look like nothing you've ever seen
before and I think that you know the
cool thing with more believable lighting
richer more detailed geometry means that
people can just believe the place is an
actual place they could visit it helps
the brain understand where they are well
the you know the other cool side effect
of having a system that is not only just
detailed but also has you know dynamic
lighting it means that environments can
be completely dynamic things can change
the cause and effect in happening games
you know we all play these big massive
games and you walk past the same but it
doesn't really change you know it's
please static most most gaming walls
right now sort of a built on this you
know building you know build as detail
as thing as you can and it's quite
static and you can't change over time
it's hard to incorporate user-generated
content with this technology it means
that walls can grow and evolve can be a
completely different thing from one day
to an X and I think that's going to open
new gameplay mechanisms that we haven't
be able to do in the past so I think
it's a pretty exciting time for for just
experimenting with totally new ideas you
guys were very effusive about the
capabilities of the playstation 5 and
the time following there are a lot of
questions around
what that means for Series X and
Microsoft and can you talk a bit about
the D dynamic and the relationship
between ue5 and Xbox series X and O Kim
earlier you mentioned that if we if we
weren't looking at this fantasy Kingdom
behind you we would see both on Xbox and
ps4 controller behind you you want to
put those conspiracies to rest oh yeah
sure you know the the DNI and the lumen
technology is built to run on you know
next-generation consoles and high-end PC
Xbox series X PlayStation 5 and you know
at least the highest high-end Nvidia and
AMD GPUs and support content that can
scale down to you know all our and
platforms we're really closely partnered
with Sonya and Emma we literally had
been talking to them for must have been
three or four or five years about not
just graphics because obviously we
talked about graphics but also storage
architecture and all the supporting
systems there needed to build next
generation games they have vast amounts
of the visual detail and need to bring
in you know detail every frame and a
very high frame rate and a very high
level fidelity the focus of that was on
the PlayStation 5 hardware it was
running on yeah we support all the
platforms but the Sony and Microsoft
first party developers are using Unreal
Engine 4 projects you've seen some ship
they're really awesome and more coming
in the future was just an author the
culmination of a really awesome
partnership they've been going on for a
very long time
no no conspiracy thing is that what you
saying no no conspiracy yeah we love all
our children and we have a very close
relationship with many of the Microsoft
Studios that are awesome Unreal Engine
users and you know I think I think the
next generation is going to be amazing
for all gamers you know regardless of
what platform you want to choose well on
all of them one of the things that you
mentioned a few times in the interview
with Geoff Keighley and also a few times
today is the the kind of relationship
with Hollywood and cinema and that kind
of stuff can you talk about what going
beyond just gaming and reaching into
Hollywood and other forms of
entertainment and media what does that
mean for you and how do you think that
will benefit games as a whole for quite
a while the the core tools that we used
to make assets for
and movies have been pretty similar
there was always has been this extra
stage of making normal Maps and low
resolution images and you know we know
that Hollywood over the last 20 years
and I was part of a Waterman film
business for a decent amount of time
making movies you know sort of pioneered
computer graphics and the pursuit of
realism so there was a lot to be learned
from then techniques and you know as we
approach you know peak photo realism for
interactive entertainment within games
we were able to sort of get ahead by
actually supporting that industry not in
a way that was a diversion
almost everything that we've done that
enables Hollywood to make better pixels
this guy is also being used by game
developers you know better blend shape
systems for faces better eye shadows
better hair we're seeing all our
developers making games that require
digital humors or digital caraxes to use
that stuff but um what what it's
definitely doing is there's the simple
effect that hey the engine produces
better-looking pixels out of the box but
the really cool thing is that we're now
seeing a crossover of the way that
people think in both industries yeah I
think you see these great storytelling
games built on our engine and other
engines are definitely using Hollywood
tricks to lens things and frame things
and help our audiences or players
understand better the story that they're
trying to take you know facial animation
technology is pretty much the same in
both industries now if you if you go and
play read every engine or a horizon zero
dawn great facial animation and it's
done you know it may not be quite at the
same fidelity today on this generation
but it will be on the next generation
it's the same stuff so the two
industries are helping each other well
there's this cool side effect of you
know working on the mandalorian were jon
favreau is able to use a real-time
engine to produce the pixels that
produce his final shots make him start
to think about oh well if we do a
dogfight here should I use gameplay
dogfights I make some vehicles I can fly
should we make a weather system and I
think eventually what's gonna happen is
there I piece will no longer be these oh
it was a movie and got converted into a
game where it was a game that becomes a
movie I think they'll be this continuum
between the two worlds and I think that
the artists will be cross over I think
that well we'll see when it comes to
content creators for making you know CGS
that's whether it's making a car or
making a chair or whatever or a rock
they'll be the same for both industries
and I see what I will see a massive
cross-pollination between these two
worlds and does that mean that games and
movies will be better yeah but I think
we'll see new types of entertainment you
look at how we're blowing the lines in
format we have concerts happening even
for Network millions of people take
place and anything entertainment is
going to go this awesome mutation over
the next five years that really bless
the line persons incredible it also
sounds like you guys are preparing to
bring back the the age of the license
game in a new way I'm very very happy to
have a love a new Batman game that's so
based on a movie or you know I just
think you you think about like imagine
I'm not don't no idea what one is
planning to do with it but imagine they
were making a new Batman game for
next-generation consoles yeah we know
that's gonna look amazing it's gonna
look pretty much like a high-end
animated movie with badass video game in
action well wouldn't it be great for
fans to go deeper and see animated
stories in that world using the same
assets and the same characters would it
be great that then things have ended
live on your Playstation file for your
next-generation Xbox and the shareable a
modifiable and but the sky's the limit I
think I think we're gonna see some
really crazy developments for the next
day my guess Tim what's it been like for
you to kind of watch this evolution
because you've been here from the start
and you know you start off making a game
engine and making games and now your
sounds like you're trying to change the
way we consume entertainment as a whole
and it's still it's called anchored on
Unreal Engine that must be my problem
right it's been an astonishing amount of
progress in the industry over the past
20 years computers are a million times
faster now for graphics processing than
they were back then so it's been really
really fantastic to see it and I think
back then in the very early days of
unreal became was becoming obvious that
your time computer graphics would have
far-reaching effects on that society it
would they just have to reach new levels
of quality to get there and it's taken a
very long time to build it out to that
point you know the point where you
actually shooting live shots and the
mandalorian wealth real-time computer
graphics backgrounds and it could be is
by architects an autumn
designers and everybody else for
photo-real versions there you know
products for for marketing and for
product visualization it's funny because
actually back in those early days it was
like 1996-97 when the cd-rom was
invented and became a widespread thing
everybody without and buying and talking
about and we had this idea of a
transmedia and of you know movie is in
television converging on games to
produce no form of entertainment and the
result was a bunch of hokey games that
were just like watching a movie and then
clicking an aesthetic choice and you
know it didn't work
look you wanted that no but it's
actually finally happening now right and
it shows that a lot of these predictions
that were made about the future that
seemed to be wrong
we're just early and are actually
happening in at scale and he'll it
definitely seems that way
stepping away into the other big thing
that you guys have going for tonight
massive success story obviously what has
been your key takeaways from four nights
growth and evolution into why it is now
I know Tim you said you don't create and
for tonight you're not mixed the for
tonight but obviously you've been the
key part of it for both of you what do
you think has been those takeaways for
you games aren't just for hardcore
gamers right games are medium that
everybody can enjoy you know the fact
that fortnight you know though it's a
battle royale game a pretty serious game
type you have to pray play pretty
seriously sorry who Jane of gamers all
sorts hardcore gamers and casual gamers
and die gamers and female gamers of all
ages as the guy has not ever been the
fortnight designer but it's been you
know what the technology advocates
behind some of the decisions we've made
it
it couldn't be happier than to see what
all the different platforms have made
possible and finally opening up and
enable the immerse to connect together
you know what are the most awesome parts
of it is that you make a traditional box
product game you make it you work very
hard you've how do you put it out and
then your fans but you don't have this
life can actually ya know the fans of
the game are they're playing it right
now as we speak millions and millions of
people having fun being connected to us
and us being connected to them is a
pretty incredible
also a huge responsibility to make sure
that we do the right thing by gamers and
and offer enough options as the game
evolves into all these different things
that they stay entertained it's
interesting is it it's a it's a little
bit akin to running a core game with a
theme park at the same time it's been a
pretty pretty exciting evolution for us
I'm gonna be honest with you I probably
write more about fall night than I
actually play and it's something I think
about almost daily because you know the
way that the world works in online print
and that kind of stuff and I just want
to go back to that time when you guys
basically hit reset on it and did that
thing where you're like the world is
exploding that was like the first time
in ages that I I knew that I didn't have
to think about covering for now for like
maybe an hour or two and it was like
life-changing it felt like the world
came to a stop and I think a lot of
people who play for tonight cover for
tonight's dreamful and I probably felt
the same way what's it like to know that
you have a game where when it stops to
be functioning it's almost as if the
world has come to a grinding halt what's
that kind of knowing that you have that
kind of impact what's that like I think
that's the neat thing about the world
therefore tonight creative TMS but yeah
they're it's a it's a magical place in
itself it is as real to people as you
know love the environments where they
live in real life and it cut transcends
everything right any game developer is
always going to be an imperfect company
are always mad at epic for this feature
that downtime or any other thing like
that but uh but the Fortnight world
itself is above it and it's kind of
separate from the company and it's as
much the product of the community as of
the company it's it's the players and
the streamers and the four-night
creative talkers that make it why it is
and if it's really a constant evolution
of the community playing at finding
things
suggesting things in the game evolving
to adapt you know with all the latest
earnings and even though I don't like to
really go out we like the team likes to
talk to the world through the game right
we'd like to go and make big statements
about our you know the creative efforts
it's it's much much more about
communicating with layers through the
evolution of what happens in the world
and it's imperfect but it is really
quite a magical thing it's it's it's
very humbling you know that that moment
it's funny I don't work directly on the
game with a lot of my friends work on
the game but we all knew that we were
going to shut it off for a period of
time and you know internally there's a
lot of you know oh my god is this the
right thing are we gonna lose authors
they're gonna be upset with us and we
don't know which regular human beings
that make video games yeah but the
lesson there for all developers is don't
be afraid to do the thing that feels a
little bit crazy and exciting I don't
don't overanalyze it like we just we
just did it and well I will we'll see
we'll see what happens and it would and
honestly many of our decisions have been
about you know just just not being super
conservative and overthinking things I
go with your gut instincts and you know
if you're if your players love your game
even if you make a mistake they cut you
you can cause correct and come back
people shouldn't be afraid to be
experimental and do new and interesting
things and I think that's one of the
most wonderful things about being part
of that began having such a humbling
audience that plays our game it's be
it's been an amazing few years yeah I
think whether you play it like hill or
not I think one thing that's not
arguable is like it's is a fascinating
game and it's constantly trying to upend
your expectations and do something
different so even as someone who is in
that moment was like great I don't have
to think about for now for a couple days
hey the whole thing really did fascinate
me I wasn't writing about it but I had
my eye on it and it wasn't just because
I was waiting for it some things happen
it was cuz I genuinely was interested in
seeing what was gonna happen next
it's almost like a impressive viewing
experience from the outside as well it's
actually one interesting thing for just
entertainment in general you know with
with the advent of streaming and people
you know things watching and just
watching stuff when they want that whole
live event you know I'm pretty old so
when I was a kid I can the UK we had
four channels and I'm 23 when I was a
little kid but that whole thing of
everybody talking about the same thing
did you see that on TV last night
like we've sort of were these live
events in our game in other games and
what they're doing doing the same thing
you universally across the planet at the
same time and get everybody talking
isn't really cool cool part of being a
human being and the fact that we are
connecting
the internet and things can spread is
really exciting and I think I hope that
the the streaming companies realize that
lot live stuff like life stop doing
something it's a pretty powerful thing
really just get people talking I mean I
think the the impact of it and fortnight
kind of leading charge is immediately
already visible like it's it's
unconfirmed in this rumors right now but
like there's talks of you know the next
Call of GE being revealed through
warzone and that that wouldn't happen
unless fortnight was doing what it did
and then non sequitur you've just
reminded me about the first time Channel
five came into existence do you remember
that no because I think well I might
have met Wendy channel 5 but I left in
97 so I I think it was like on the cusp
of me of me coming moving to America
yeah I think it I think it was it would
probably have been after that because I
remember being in the teenager years and
it blew my mind that another channel
could just be created and added to
television yeah it's amazing ridiculous
TV coming into our house for the longest
time I used to play my Sega Megadrive on
a black and white TV and even when color
TVs existed and I was like playing
Aladdin on in black and white was my saw
and when I play a lot in now I'm like if
he was wrong because it's colored I'm
like this should be in black and white
Tim how you doing there with your diet
coke in a Popeye's cup still good yeah
it's good fantastic one of the other key
things that you talked about and
announced afterwards was the changes of
the epic online service things that were
happening you kind of have your
empowering people with more you know
connectivity and networking options can
you talk a bit about that and what
effect you potentially see it having on
the wider gaming in district sure you
know since 2012 we've been voting this
really extensive set of backend systems
were for all other games to provide
accounts and social features and friends
were recommend voice and other
communication features all of the
services need to match make players
together into a cross-platform game
experience and so uh either epic online
service initiative is aimed at opening
up all that stuff we built onto all
other game developers for free
it's really especially especially
targeted at the cross-platform problem
because if you look at voting in a game
and shipping in a lot of platforms this
xbox ID there's PlayStation Network
there's the Nintendo online services and
then there's steam and you no other
service is proprietary to each publisher
but you're shipping a multi-platform
game each one is is still a lot to only
interoperate with players on the same
device family um and so you know by
integrating the epic services you can
use platform services side by side with
auntie platform services and really
connect all of your players you know
when you look at for Knights growth
there are really two big growth spurts
one began when the battle royale mode
launched just had this magical
combination gameplay that created a new
type of experience but the other major
growth spurt occurred when we connected
all of the platforms together and they
want everybody to play with all of their
friends everywhere and people would play
together with their friends spend a lot
more time playing the game together they
enjoyed the game more and spend more
money every aspect of the game
experience becomes better for them and
better for the game developers too when
you have a complete social framework
like that opening up to all developers
is a way of jump-starting that and we do
it for free too you know I did the cost
of operating these services is fairly
small we're not running we're not
offering free game servers right those
are massively expensive and consuming
each month harder Northstar we're
talking about friends and accounts
matchmaking and these kind of a
synchronous back-end services and so the
cost of operating as well enough that
we're able to offer to all developers
for free and we benefit by the growth of
the player network every time a new game
gamer comes in and creates an account
and every time they make their friends
in the game that friends relationships
benefits every game that uses the
service is including ours and so it's
really a great collective way for the
game industry to kind of approach the
next generation of cross-platform
features together epic and butan
specifically have been big proponents of
cross-platform play and creating a
homogeneous kind of environment for
everyone to kind of play together we've
made some inroads there you know some
companies have been a little more vocal
about being into the idea while others
are also
they have some walls around their
gardens so to speak why do you think
it's important to have this and what
would you say to anyone developer
publisher or even platform holder there
might still be gingerly kind of
approaching it and might still have some
thoughts about trying to maintain these
walled gardens right now every platform
supports a cross-platform play and in
none of its cases has it been a special
exception made just for fortnight in
every case Sony and Microsoft and
Nintendo have opened this up as a
general program any developer can
participate in there are always a lot of
business courses shaping all this a lot
of fear of the unknown and recognition
of you know if we can connect these
devices together then you know what will
happen will will the internet blow up
and will players be able to trust
players on other devices but you know
it's work out remarkably low and there's
been in stone just a wonderful community
around for tonight really I think
village toxic toxicity community you see
in game and as a result of the kind of
style of the game in the spirit of the
gameplay we're super happy with where
all the console makers Dan natives soft
all the all the challenges and all the
concerns we had in the past and we've
had a little bit vocal about that's
right we've had some disagreements with
folks over cross-platform play but those
are all solved and we have some
disagreements with the mobile platforms
right now ever that the business
practices and I think that's going to be
another frontier that the whole game
industry is going to need to work
together to push forward over this next
generation you know in the spirit of
having open platforms which all
developers can participate and freely
I'm gonna be honest with you guys I
really miss seeing the plasma ball on a
background Kim I like your background
currently but earlier you showed me
something I am and I've got my awesome
class on the ball in the batteries
my game is yes that's more like it thank
you - please plug in for us it's just
it's summer there you go that's there it
is but I was having a little bit of a
plasma run war with with Tim the other
the other day so we upgraded I leveled
off yeah
this thing open up puts out set on time
I go down don't yeah don't do that
if imagine if Tim's just ends this
interview because you can sheer force of
power coming yeah that's more like your
one looks bad but I'm gonna be honest
Kim you've got some like megalomaniac
and villain energy going on with you
right now like just it looks like you're
about to plot world domination which I
guess if if Unreal Engine 5 goes the way
you want maybe is the case I'll just go
back into my construct yeah if you know
that's good that's good that's pretty
good thank you so much for putting the
both of you for giving us a bit over
that hit of the plasma balls I'm very
excited blow it away and not bring it
out until there's another Diet Coke
spill moving on Epic Games Thor that's
been a huge initiative for you guys
recently you wanted it to be a kind of
challenger to the status quo and when it
came to digital delivery and to be
almost kind of a disruptive element in
the industry has that been the case and
how has that been received by the wider
game industry it was a daunting
challenge right this is challenging an
entrenched competitor in a very
well-established market is is fraught
with peril and if you look at the the
previous stores that launched on PC diag
og and humble both are really awesome
stores um both of them launched with a
lot more features in the epic game store
head but both of them spent years
getting up to the point of having like
half a percent of market or 1% of market
share and so your eyes turning on we
need to take a a really really board
approach and a disruptive approach and
so free game program was launched
exclusives were launched and you know a
lot of things that we knew would be a be
controversial in some ways especially
with the hardcore you know Steam gamers
who bought hundreds of games on Steam
and Lullaby all their games on Steam but
it's work incredibly well you know in
our first 15 months we ended up with
about fifteen percent market share it's
still growing our usage rate our monthly
active users since that point when we
started announcing those
numbers have gone up and more than
doubled um and so we what we see is a
really healthy robust alternate store
ecosystem growing and bringing these
better economics to all developers you
know the revenue sharing giving
developers 88% of the revenue instead of
70% really is aimed it shaking up the
economics and all of the open platforms
and platforms that should be open and
we'd like to bring the store to iOS in
the future and we will bring it Android
we think it's a good way to help the
industry forward and it's another way
where you know epic as a game developer
had vote up this audience around
fortnight and learned it how to operate
distribution platform on PC and Android
and now as we've done with many things
from the Unreal Engine online services
we open it up to all other developers to
use with their game Center and trying to
serve the industry and provide a really
interesting that alternative TFS system
but it's a it's been funny there are a
lot of PC gamers who just like to buy
everything on Steam and so it like kind
of I'm seeing as like the arch-nemesis
of these all right core PC gamer isn't
it's funny too because if you see in
that way to grow enemy to them all
especially considering your background
and I mean the connection to Unreal and
Unreal Tournament and if anything you're
still kind of the kind of one of their
forefathers of modern PC gaming and epic
is that way too so it's quite ironic
that you might be seen that way
for a lot of people maybe it's just the
old people that remember at this point
but oh you know it takes a lot to change
it in industry I think the industry yeah
the game industry so needs to evolve and
change further I think the way the cross
played was opened up in this generation
has been wonderful than for games and
it's going to be even bigger and even
better in the next generation as it
becomes more pervasive across lots of
games and across publishers but you know
if these store bought has to change too
it's because I was saying about the
engine and important to developer
productivity that the hardest problem in
the game business for game developers
isn't even the creative and technical
work that they have to do it's a it's
just the sheer cost of building these
products that holds everybody back and
it's lemon
factor and so wherever you can ensure
that more of the money that consumers
spend on games goes into the pockets of
game developers and nut middlemen
including us as a middleman that's a
great thing for for the entire game
business fit it will lead to better
games and better economics for everybody
obviously one of the things that I and
various other people who use Epic Games
for love is free games is that something
you intend intend to continue doing for
the foreseeable future is it sustainable
from a business side and for you and
your partners I think someone calculated
you've done like like eight thousand
dollars worth a game for something like
that maybe but it's that kind of like so
that process are actually really amazing
so you know by doing a bulk deal with
the game developer where we buy a lot of
basically just pay them for the right to
release their game for free for one week
we've been able to get an amazing array
of games to gamers including getting
people to play games with types genres
they never thought about playing before
you're not going to go out and buy if
you're not into you know games like
satisfactory you're not going to go and
spend money to buy satisfactory but if
you get for free your eyes an awesome
game people have discovered love games
that way it's it's been a boon for game
developers most twelvers who launch
their games for free on the store
founded their sales on Steam and on
console platforms actually increased
after they went free and epic because of
increased awareness and so so it's been
a really positive thing and it's also
it's brought a lot of its what tens of
millions of new users into the epic
games ecosystem that's been a wonderful
thing for the company
fantastic well I think sadly we're out
of time but Tim can thank you so much
for spending upwards of an hour talking
to us and we really appreciate it and we
look forward to seeing more from you
guys and seeing what the future holds
for Unreal Engine it was awesome I lost
you did a fantastic job interviews
really thank you so much I appreciate it
have a great day guys thank you thank
you
[Music]
you